when I lived in New York watching people
lose on three card Monty was my favorite
activity really well because I worked on
Broadway because I I was a PA on the
first season of peewee's playhouse which
was on Broadway didn't know that they
didn't yeah they moved to California
after but the first season was in New
York and right down below you know the
guys that set up their cardboard boxes I
just stand there at my lunch hour and
watch the whole time just watching
people lose I just thought it was the
funniest thing how did you get a job
with uh Paul with Paul Reuben as well it
was this production company called
broadcast darts and they mostly did
television commercials and my friend
worked there he was an artist and he
just got me a job there as like a
messenger or something and then I guess
they had done these kind of like really
hip new wavy Twizzlers commercials right
back then in like what was it in 1983 I
guess they seemed hip and cool and hip
and cool and Twizzler you don't hear a
lot in the same sense I guess they were
a new wavy and maybe they seemed like
Cutting Edge I don't know right and then
one day they're like oh we're gonna
start doing this thing with Pee Wee
Herman they didn't even really even know
who he was I don't think they sent me up
to down to go buy like a video like
still it was like 100 bucks to buy a VHS
tape of uh
peewee's big adventure or something
because they weren't that familiar with
them the movie yeah yeah just kiwi in
general but I know were you I was
because I had seen him on some HBO
Comedy thing the first time and I was
like this guy's amazing so I'd always
right so you were on the set
yeah now and then like there was two
buildings this was the office where they
did all the animation like the dinosaur
family and stuff and then down the
street was where they built the
playhouse and I would go there sometimes
to deliver stuff I only talked to Paul
Rubens once he asked me where the
bathroom was and I was like it's right
over there wow that was the only time I
talked to him wow so but people don't
know that that happened yeah it was cool
like people watched that show or know
the history of Paul Rubens but don't
know that Rob Zombie directed him to the
men and that season was amazing because
it was Phil Hartman and Larry Fishburn
and all like there was Larry Fishburne
was the cowboy guy Cowboy Curtis yes and
uh Phil Hartman was the guy with the the
yeah I can't remember his character's
name
there's a lot of great people yeah I'm
amazed that that show didn't come back
[Music]